ja mitten im sommer zittern die
deutschen schon beim gedanken an den
winter und jetzt jetzt bröckelt auch
noch der letzte anker aller verbraucher
sollte das gas knapp werden bisher hieß
es ja immer private haushalte sind
sicher der gashahn wird nicht gekauft
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
hat jetzt allerdings zum ersten mal
diese priorisierung in frage gestellt
niemand soll frieren aber das private
haushalte auch ihren anteil leisten und
dass eine dauerhafte oder langfristige
unterbrechung von industrieller
produktion massive folgen auch für die
gesamtwirtschaft hat für die menschen im
land für die versorgungssituation das
denke ich ist inzwischen auch erkannt
und genau darüber wollen wir sprechen
mit bildpolitik chef jan schäfer schönen
guten morgen jan simon ja das war ja der
letzte anker dass diese priorisierung
eben nicht eintritt dass die privaten
haushalte verschont bleiben bröckelt das
jetzt oder müssen wir alle auf den
milden winter einfach nur hoffen wir
müssen auf einen milden winter hoffen
ohne frage angesichts der situation der
wir uns alle befinden und das was robert
habeck anspricht das tut er ja
eigentlich auch schon seit längerer zeit
also erfordert die bundesbürger ja aber
auch die unternehmen auf strom und
energie zu sparen wo ist eigentlich nur
geht hat sogar angeregt auch weniger zu
duschen das heißt robert habeck ist so
etwas wie ein ja energie verhinderungs
oder drosselung minister der zeit und in
dieser situation und auch mit diesem
mantra ist ja gestern eben auch in wien
aufgetreten jetzt gibt es natürlich die
frage privathaushalt der anker sozusagen
für uns dass der gashahn nicht gekappt
wird aber sind wir dazu egoistisch gibt
es industrien die wirklich viel viel
dringend da das gas brauchen also wenn
es nach ihr ginge wer würde priorisiert
werden das was robert habe gerade gesagt
hat ist ja auch bezug auf einen längeren
zeitraum und es gibt diese priorisierung
vollkommen richtig und die ist sozusagen
auch von brüssel von der eu aus
vorgegeben für die eu die könnte man
auch nicht so ohne weiteres einfach
ändern was robert habeck sagt ist wenn
wir in einem langen prozess kommen und
es einen richtigen streit um die frage
geht also wer bekommt denn eigentlich
noch richtig gas und energie dann sagt
er natürlich auch als
wirtschaftsminister dass es verständlich
kann ich natürlich nicht den unternehmen
sagen ihr dürft jetzt also nicht mehr
produzieren damit und überspitzte jetzt
ganz bewusst die bundesbürger aber alle
kuschelig warm zu hause in ihren
wohnungen sitzen das ist so das feld auf
dem er sich bewegt und wenn wir
priorisieren müssen dann ist natürlich
ganz klar es geht um die älteren
menschen es geht vor allem auch um die
kranken menschen also es geht um die die
wirklich wärme und energie nötig haben
um zu überleben und jemand wie ich kann
sicherlich auch auf ein bisschen gas und
energie eher verzichten sich einfach in
wärmeren pullover
überstülpen im winter ohne dass ich
jetzt sage dass das eine tolle situation
ist keine frage das müssen wir auf jeden
fall natürlich irgendwie zu verhindern
versuchen gas triage wird sich wirklich
schlimm an das hat es in deutschland so
eben noch nicht gegeben wenn es dann so
weit kommen dass gerade gesprochen von
der priorisierung also dass
krankenhäuser altenheime natürlich so
lange wie möglich im warmen eben sein
sollen und die privaten haushalte
vielleicht hinten anstehen müssen aber
wenn es tatsächlich dann so eintritt ist
das natürlich für alle betroffenen dann
sehr sehr hart das ist absolut hat das
ist ein extremfall und das ist sowohl
für die verbraucher wie aber auch die
industrie oder alle unternehmen
natürlich ein richtiger schlag ins
kontor und das kann auch bedeuten dass
firmen menschen entlassen müssen
mitarbeiter entlassen müssen das würde
dann die arbeitslosigkeit erhöhen das
heißt er würden menschen möglicherweise
zu hause ihre heizung runterdrehen
müssen und dann auch noch ihren job
verlieren das trifft die dann doppelt
hat das ist wirklich ein drama in das
weder möglicherweise hineinlaufen aber
wir sehen auch und dass er robert habeck
auch noch einmal betont das sind extreme
fehler die in der vergangenheit gemacht
wurden man muss sich immer wieder fragen
wie konnte eigentlich eine
bundesregierung wie bei bild haben das
ja auch immer wieder beklagt wie konnte
eine bundesregierung sich in den
vergangen jahren so in die abhängigkeit
von russland von einem despoten geben
und am ende mit mehr als 50 gasimporte
aus russland dastehen das ist eigentlich
im nachhinein betrachtet noch mal eine
totale katastrophe
glaubst du dass das schon bei allen
deutschen angekommen ist diese
abhängigkeit einerseits und andererseits
diese haltung naja dann sehen wir uns
halt im winter malen polymer an es ist
bemerkenswert dass viele deutsche das
natürlich jetzt genauso sehen aber auf
der anderen seite bemerkenswert ist dass
viele die dafür verantwortlich sind dass
wir in dieser abhängigkeit sind
einfach noch in spitzenämtern in der
deutschen politik setzen beispielsweise
bundespräsident weiter sprang weiter
steinmeier der an vorderster front für
nord stream zwei beispielsweise auch für
die gas abhängigkeit zu russland
gekämpft was ist mit manuela schwesig
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern die ebenfalls immerhin noch
in ihrem spitzenamt sitzt aber auch
massiv die kontakte nach russland
gepflegt hat und die gasimporte aus
russland ausbauen wollte und auch immer
verteidigt hat michael kretschmer ist
auch der sächsische ministerpräsident
jemand der einen ganz ganz engen draht
zu russland pflegt und auch den
austausch und die gasimporte und die
abhängigkeit von russland eigentlich
immer wieder verteidigt hat das heißt
wir sehen es gibt politiker in
spitzenämtern die uns das mehr oder
weniger eingebrockt haben dieses dilemma
und bisher aber keine konsequenzen
gezogen haben jetzt müssen die bürger
das beste daraus machen vielen dank bild
politik chef jan schäfer danke dir